you've just had a night of your life in
beautiful las vegas nevada
you spend hours shooting crafts dancing
in clubs and eating more than your fill
at the famous
all-you-can-eat buffets you're
staggering back to your hotel room
high on life in the early hours of the
morning when you noticed something
strange
a long dark tunnel just off the side of
the strip
you didn't notice it on the way in
perhaps because you were distracted by
all the glitz
glamour and hypnotic casino lights you
see the tunnel
and your overstimulated mind feels drawn
to it
you stumble in and start walking during
your walk
you can feel your bones cracking they
don't shatter
like you've just been hit by a train
they
shift you feel the entire shape of you
bending into something different
but it doesn't stop with your skeleton
your organs start to feel strange
and then your skin in the complete
darkness of the tunnel
you have no idea what's going on so you
just
keep walking eventually you find your
way into a lush green forest
it's beautiful but it feels like it
should be a million miles away from the
arid desert of nevada
you were only in the tunnel for a few
minutes what gives
hello you call out is anybody there no
answer
you explore further into this empty
forest its trees are far as the eye can
see but no animals that's when you see
something that catches your eye a puddle
of crystal clear water
but it's not the puddle itself that
draws your attention
it's what reflects back at you when you
stare
into it at first you can hardly believe
it but as you move your mouth in shock
and the reflection moves its mouth too
it's suddenly
all too real you've been turned into a
fox
an orange bushy-tailed fox you screamed
and bolt all the way back to the tunnel
that led you here you sprint through
and feel your entire body changing once
more when you finally hit the wall of
dry
vegas heat on the other side you're
human again
you breathe a sigh of relief and stumble
back to your hotel room
the next day you only vaguely remember
what happened
and because you're not crazy you assume
it was just
all a wild dream what you just
encountered is a euclid-class
scp known as scp-2746
seemingly innocent tunnel near the vegas
strip which holds a portal to a
fantastical world
designated by the foundation as
scp-2746-1
by the time the foundation discovered
and secured the scp-2746
tunnel and began sending their field
agents and researchers on fact-finding
expeditions inside
the place was already a ghost town a
forested land mass approximately 111
kilometers in diameter
with no notable signs of life the
foundation discovered that this place
had a strange effect on people and
animals who came in from our world
humans who entered assumed the form of a
random animal
but retained their intelligence and
vocal cords creating talking animals
animals brought into 2746-1 retained
their animalistic intelligence
but grew human-like vocal cords allowing
them to repeat simple phrases
before the mass exodus or extinction
event that left 2746-1 barren
the foundation figured out that this
place was populated by a whole
civilization of intelligent animals
like something out of a fairy tale these
animals
through a mix of brains and magic were
able to leave
written records and create impressive
architecture like homes and places of
worship
foundation researchers became fascinated
with how exactly
this society operated and what could
have led to its sudden downfall
thanks to a mix of advanced archaeology
and records left behind by the creatures
this is what the foundation determined
the society
these talking intelligent animals lived
in was a kind of religious oligarchy
meaning power was consolidated by the
few in the top social class
society was divided into three segments
crafters
scholars and honorables with the
crafters being the most powerful members
of society
and honorables being the least powerful
the state-sponsored churches acted in
worship of a being simply called the
maker
who fills a similar role to the
abrahamic god the crafters
whose number totaled 13 were believed to
be immortal
and were responsible for building the
majority of the culture
and architecture found in 2746-1
the scholars acted as their wise
assistants and the honorables were a
mixed class of artists
carpenters and artisans it seemed that
this culture had a pretty good thing
going no system of currency was ever
invented
and the economy operated on a barter
system the foundation believes that
initially
the citizens of this world didn't need
to eat to survive
and so only needed to barter for
material goods
though it's worth noting that the
conditions of immortality only apply to
natives of this region
people born on earth but assuming animal
forms while entering 2746-1
still need nutrition to survive however
a great tragedy soon caused a
fundamental shift in the balance of life
and society within 2746-1
the maker decided it wanted to test or
punish its subjects with two major
changes
first humans would be forbidden from
entering the domain
and second the maker now made the
consumption of food necessary for
continued survival
and sanity nothing was ever the same
because nobody had needed to eat prior
to this food stores had never been made
and the inhabitants had no agricultural
knowledge that would allow them to
easily mass produce more
as a result while the crafters and
scholars were able to feed on fruits
from luxurious private gardens
the honorables were forced to resort to
eating each other
or other inhabitants of 2746-1
this began a bloody rift that split
society from the top down
one half led by the powerful crafters
sari and suward
wanted to preserve society as it was and
continue to worship the maker
sari took the form of a flemish giant
rabbit and siouard appeared as a house
cat
the opposition led by former crafters
frederick and agathos
with the reluctant help of a scholar
named clovis wanted to get revenge on
the maker for
all he'd done and kill him completely
altering society
don't be fooled by their appearances
though many of the inhabitants of 2746-1
were fiercely intelligent sorcerers
and the apocalyptic civil war they
sparked came to be known to the
foundation as
event like many wars there would be no
real winners here
only survivors and even then not for
long
it was a bloody and horrific war all
attempts at finding a diplomatic
solution
failed frederick and agathos would not
stop until they had the maker's blood on
their paws
in the end though they were defeated and
for their traitorous crimes they were to
be punished by sari and sue ward in
horrific ways to make examples of them
since neither could die they were given
fates worse than death
instead frederick was up first before
the war he'd been a leader prize for his
courage
and ingenuity he created something known
as the great fire
which provided the kingdom with light
for his so-called
atrocities against the maker he was
given the punishment of permanent
crucifixion
and relocation to a place known as the
underplane
his snout was cut off his face and he
was set permanently ablaze
in a manner that would leave him forever
suffering and would make him appear to
look like a monster
to all next when agathos she was
frederick's sister
and was seen as the mastermind of many
of their schemes
she would be forever encased in white
clay and bled through her eyes until the
sin drains from her
she's now a living crying statue
existing in a state of permanent
imprisonment for her part in the crimes
against the maker
clovis because her involvement of the
coop was unwilling
was given a more minor punishment one of
her eyes was removed
and she was permanently placed in a
broken human body
effectively banishing her from her home
in 2746-1
forever though they may have won things
didn't end much better for sari and siwa
the civil war had fractured their world
and in the aftermath
the survivors chose to leave in hopes of
finding a better life elsewhere
zari and sewer though felt partially
responsible for everything that had
happened
and so they decided to remain in their
dying world
before they themselves died or perhaps
moved on to different forms
leaving their animal bodies behind they
left a final note
it was from this note that the
foundation learned much of the story of
scp-2746 this may
seem like a pretty open and shut case
another magical realm
destroyed by tragedy and civil war much
like the land of fantasy
and scp-1762 but what's really bizarre
here is that this is only the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to the stories of
some of these key figures in the event
nach
first what became of the two rebels
agathos and frederick
today they're two parts of the feared
and deadly scp-1913
frederick now going by freddy is a
nightmarish faceless fire demon in the
form of a dog
slavishly devoted to the protection of
his sister
agathos now known as agatha still
trapped in white clay
her leaking blood now deadly to the
touch clovis is still believed to be in
league with agathos and frederick
and may now be related to the sinister
scp-1903
a one-eyed rabbit-like human but
strangest of all
is the possible truth behind sari and
sewer the two devotees to the maker who
remained in 2746-1
until their very last breath in all
likelihood
these two were once agents of the scp
foundation's infamous las vegas branch
they took on these more animalistic
forms after their deaths
sorry may have once been agent sarah
crowley a japanese-american woman who
died in the line of duty in 1960.
seward was once dr stuart hayward
crowley's partner
his new name acting as a kind of fusion
of the first and last name
he had in life this is only the
beginning of the animal-themed weirdness
occurring around site-45
the foundation's vegas branch but this
series of anomalies collected under the
term pitch haven
will have to wait for another video
after all
you know what they say what happens in
vegas
stays in vegas now go check out scp-001
the scarlet king and scp-2317 the devour
of worlds a door to another world
for more mind-blowing accounts from the
scp foundation